when you went in the studio made this
song Truth Hurts the DNA line the why
men got to be great is that all written
down ahead of time or are you just
coming up with that in the studio funny
thing about that is it's a combination
of both so the day I went in the studio
to record that song specifically truth
hurts
um I was going through
you know some some personal
issues and I was sad and everything that
was happening to me Ricky Reed was
writing it down and he was like do you
realize you just wrote a song and I was
like no I'm crying right now and then we
put it together that way you mean you
went in the studio and said why why men
great till they got to be great and
don't text me tell it straight to my
face you were you were just kind of
unloading yeah oh wow I literally went
straight to the salon got my hair done I
literally went on a date with a
Minnesota Viking like everything and
then the bum bum Bombay was a filler I
just was like let's just put this in
there until we find a better line and
then it just kind of stuck like
everything was just like a stream of
conscious